a neurologist as a physician expects
people to come to him with problems
people who are suffering people who are
disabled people who have complaints it
is extremely unusual for example to
receive as I mentioned earlier a letter
from someone who describes an
achievement like my lady who said that
she had suddenly achieved stereo vision
and her life had been wonderfully
enlarged most of the people who come to
me say their life has been diminished or
shrunken or affected by whatever it is
but having said that and and and as a
physician if the if the if the disease
or problem it can't be treated as such
which may be the case I mean there may
be some forms of brain damage or spinal
damage which are there you have to
accept it but then then the real
challenge is to find other ways of
living and making the fullest possible
life and identity using if you want sort
of other parts of the brain and
compensating I mean I'll give you a
specific example it's easier for me to
think in specific terms i i i was
consulted by a writer a novelist who on
one occasion he um had breakfast he felt
fine he went to get the newspaper
outside and fact was the Toronto Globe
and Mail and he found it unintelligible
it clearly was the newspaper but he
couldn't make anything of the print
he had a moment.we feeling that the
paper was printed and serbo-croat
or something and he had what's called a
visual Alexia
he'd had a small stroke affecting the
visual parts of the brain and for a
writer above all people to be suddenly
unable to read it
interestingly he was able to write but
he then couldn't read what he had
written
and he was devastated by this didn't
know how he was going to survive as a
writer or some person and after a while
it seemed to him that he was learning to
read again that he was awake recovering
but in fact when he was tested there was
no recovery of the visual Alexia and
what was happening unconsciously
was that his tongue was copying the
shapes of letters on his palate and
since the disease only affects the
visual basically he was reading with his
tongue so part of my work as a
neurologist is to find and help people
discover other other ways of doing
things
Tourette syndrome can um can make life
very difficult for one but in a sense
there could be another side to it as
well
because once one's thoughts are
accelerated what one's coordination may
be particularly quick emotions and
imagination may be stimulated and
there's a sort of positive side to this
in a way to it is a turned on state and
and this can sometimes be be be utilized
there's some there's some very good
athletes with to it's very good sort of
musicians and performers with Tourette's
and perhaps if one sees someone with
something like Tourette syndrome it's
good to explore possible positive sides
of it and then the person will it's so I
don't say there's always a positive side
but about but I think it's very
important to to look and not just simply
to think in terms of defects and
problems but of different ways of doing
things and different ways of functioning
and this has now become almost a
political thing so that say people with
autism will would you know like to UM
refer sometimes almost contemptuously to
the rest of us as neurotypical so I
think the idea
of neurological differences and styles
is is very important although although
it although one can go over the top with
it it's a it is a delicate matter